la tendance 54 on a deux rouges
du vôtre en six matches un corner même
largement favori et rassuré par les
premiers résultats qui arrivent de
plusieurs bureaux avant 20 heures didier
martin refusaient encore de crier
victoire trop tôt
j'ai continué à faire une campagne de
proximité tout au long de cette semaine
en allant dans les villages en allant
dans les quartiers on rencontrera le
maximum de gens accueillent a plutôt été
favorable mais que diront les électeurs
je ne sais pas une heure plus tard les
félicitations de daniel juba la
référente départementale dans marche
la première circonscription tombe elle
aussi dans l'escarcelle de la majorité
présidentielle une dynamique contre
laquelle françois xavier dugourd n'a
rien pu faire la famille des
républicains a beau s'être rassemblés
autour de sa candidature pour le
deuxième tour
le compte n'y est pas elle a résisté je
crois qu il ya une mobilisation
importante des électeurs et j'existe
peut être considérée comme un bon
résultat également pour l'avenir
d'accord vous n'êtes pas si déçu que ça
le déçu d'avoir perdu on est toujours
déçu de perdre une élection c'est une
évidence mais le score ce n'est pas
mauvais honnêtement objectivement un
quand on parle de 4800 voit qu'on arrive
à près de 13000 ça veut dire que bon la
l1 mobiliser largement mais pas encore
suffisamment le vice président du
conseil départemental termine près de
neuf points derrière le candidat dans
marche